well the vaccine approval comes as the
pandemic is taking its heaviest toll
yet on the american public friday saw
more deaths in a single day
more than 3 300 since the pandemic began
the virus has killed more than 295
thousand americans
also on friday a record 231 thousand new
cases were reported
bringing the total number of infections
in this country to nearly
16 million and as janet chandlian
reports health care workers say now is
not the time
to let your guard down
an unthinkable record coronavirus deaths
topping 3 000
for a second consecutive day
california reporting the highest number
of new cases ever
mississippi is completely out of icu
beds
fort worth texas is doubling capacity at
the morgue
and in new york city indoor dining shut
down starting monday
the rate of transmission and the density
and the crowding
that is a bad situation the horrifying
death toll includes names
like stephanie smith 29 years old about
to be married
she should have been on her honeymoon
the day she died
as physicians we've been trained to
help people and it's really hard right
now to feel
helpless dr shirley z says if only the
doubters and non-maskers could spend
one day like she does take a walk
in my shoes and you'll get on that phone
and you call the son
to tell him that his father
who had grown up alone and an orphan
died the same way because i couldn't get
into the room
soon enough to hold his hand while he
passed away
i'm not somebody's family i can't ever
become
their family i can't talk to a patient
without a mask on
i can't touch them without gloves on and
i
you know they they die and they never
see our faces
dr z says hospitals can find more beds
but they are
out of health care workers we can't call
on anyone to help us
if we run out of staff to take patience
if we stop
masking or if we stop distancing
just we're gonna lose so many more
people before we get to the end
what a toll this has taken on health
care workers like dr
z and there's a sobering statistic if
three thousand people continue to die
each day in two weeks christmas day
that's 42 000
lives lost that number enough to fill
houston's major league baseball
stadium for cbs this morning saturday
janet chameleon
houston